- If a man cat called me,
I'd be able to make him
feel menstrual cramps immediately.
(playful music)
- Today, I'm gonna
create my own Superpower
to deal with cat callers.
Kick in the face.
You guys didn't see my panties
when I did that did you?
- Cat callin' has been goin' on
ever since I came out the womb.
- It would usually be teenage
boys when I was a teenager.
So at the time, I kinda
took it as flattering.
But then, as I got older
and realized they would
literally cat call anything that moved.
- A construction worker said
"look at the tits on that".
- I even remember what I was wearing
the first time I got cat called.
I was 12 and I didn't understand
that you couldn't wear
a denim jacket as an actual top.
- Look at the tits on
her, you know what I mean,
it's like you're objectifying my boobs,
but then you're also
objectifying the rest of me.
- It's always the dustiest dude.
It's always the guy who has like,
the ketchup stain on his white tee.
- They have cat calls
down for regular women,
but then when they see a pregnant woman,
there is sort of this surprise like
"Whoa whoa whoa! There's a
lady with somethin' in her!
I wanna put my dick in her!"
- When they cat call me
they try to be polite.
Like, "Well uh, you got nice
ankles, I can see those ank,
those are very moisturized
ankles. I see you".
- I'm not here for any guy
that tells me to smile.
Like, my face, is always resting.
- Whenever a guy tries to cat call me,
I would teleport his mother
to the scene of the crime.
Because I would like to say,
could you cat call me
in front of your mother?
- When a guy cat calls
me, I could make myself
invisible, just whispering
objectifying things in his ear
and slowly drive him insane.
- My super power would be,
making their pants disappear.
- I would fart on command.
I know some people say they
can actually fart on command.
I am not capable of that.
- If a man cat called me,
I'd be able to make him
feel menstrual cramps immediately.
- Not only is it gonna smell,
it's also gonna sting the eyes.
I think it would sort of have a
similar effect to pepper spray.
- My hair would turn into snakes
as soon as somebody cat called me.
The biggest snake would eat his head,
and the rest of his body
would just stay there.
- Looking at your body makes me so hungry!
Mmm, I just want to eat you
like you were a burrito!
- Hello Mrs. Jackson, do you know your son
was cat calling me today?
He said I had a fat ass.
- You don't have any pants on.
- Does he usually talk
like that in front of you?
Mrs. Jackson, do I have a fat ass?
- Oh how does it feel to be exposed?
How does it feel for everyone
to look at your body?
- You like my ass?
How 'bout now?
(fart noises)
- Does your dick hurt now?
I bet you also have diarrhea.
Are people honest about that?
That you have diarrhea
when you have your period?
- Why don't you smile?
If women had superpowers
and could use them
against cat callers, it'd be
a completely different world.
- Most of the time, I usually want to meet
these guys mothers anyway, 'cause I'm like
"Who raised you to cat
call, at 2pm on a Monday?"
- Well it felt great to have
snakes coming out of my hair.
I don't even like snakes, but
if I don't have to see them,
and they do all the work
for me, then I love snakes.
- Evolution wise, men would like,
find a way to get past the superpowers.
- They might stop cat calling out of fear.
But probably not, 'cause they are men.
(upbeat music)
(sign squeaking)